l'application de française stop qu'ovide
enterré depuis le 22 octobre 2020 refait
parler d'elle on se souvient des
polémiques liées à ce top cow vide au
sujet des données personnelles puis de
sa technologie puis de son faible taux
de téléchargement et aujourd'hui c'est
au tour de l'association anticor
d'agiter l'épouvantail
l'organisation anticorruption a porté
plainte en janvier contre le ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand selon anticor
les contrats de gestion de l'application
noms ont été soumis à aucune procédure
de passation de marchés publics
l'association rappelle dans sa plainte
que le code de la commande publique
exige cette procédure pour les contrats
supérieurs à cent trente neuf mille
euros hors taxes on se souvient encore
que le 27 mai 2020 cedrico le secrétaire
d'état au numérique s'était targuée
d'avoir développé l'application grâce au
concours d'agent ce public et de start
up
intervenant à titre gracieux la
participation des entreprises privées au
développement a été gratuit je m'en
félicite l'entreprise l'une habits dont
on parle dans les médias qui est à
chambéry je crois que ces 15 personnes
pendant plusieurs semaines sept de ces
développeurs ont travaillé gratuitement
pour aider l'état à développer une
application sanitaires je voulais
remercier tout comme je vais remercier
tous les grands groupes toutes les
autres certains qui ont travaillé sur le
sujet quelle fin négociateur
mais en réalité dès le démarrage de
l'application de contacts racing en juin
les entreprises ont logiquement commencé
à être rémunéré et la douloureuse a
atteint un montant compris entre 200
milles et 300000 euros par mois
régler à capgemini la start-up l'une à
bille ou encore outscale une filiale de
dassault systèmes qui assure
l'hébergement et la maintenance
40000 euros mensuels pour l'hébergement
informatique 40000 à 80000 euros par
mois pour la maintenance et le
développement
cinquante mille euros par mois d'appui
au support utilisateur trente mille
euros par mois pour les frais de
déploiement
ce à quoi il faut ajouter près de 3
millions d'euros de campagne de
communication l'attribution de tous ces
marchés a attiré l'attention d'anticorps
qui porte donc plainte
chacun des postes de dépenses qu'il
s'agisse de la communication ou de
l'exploitation de l'application aurait
dû faire l'objet d'un appel d'offres ou
d'une procédure de mise en concurrence
au regard de leur montant sans même
tranchée sur un éventuel favoritisme ces
montants élevés seraient moins polémique
six top cow vide avait été un succès
stop coville n'a été téléchargé que deux
lyon deux fois désinstaller un million
de fois et réinstaller 300 mille fois le
rapport de la commission d' enquête sur
la gestion gouvernementale de l'épidémie
rendu en décembre 2020 a étrillé le
bilan de ce top cow vide
l'état a dépensé 6 5 millions d'euros
pour 5553 test positif scanner dans
l'application 346 alerte dont 296
effectivement transmises ça fait cher
l'alertent presque 22000 euros
mais il existe une raison de se réjouir
tel le phénix stop qu'ovide a pu
renaître de ses cendres en octobre en
version améliorée plus précises et
complètes sous le nom de tous antico
vide et cette fois-ci les français l'ont
téléchargée 13,9 millions de fois et
l'apli a émis cent mille alerte c'est
bien mieux
alors voyons ce qu'ont pensé internautes
dans les avis suite à la dernière mise à
jour l'application ne fonctionne plus à
chaque lancement j'ai le message
impossible d'initialiser antico vide
ge a été testée positive le 19 mars j'ai
rentrer le code pour me signaler dans
l'après midi même et nous sommes le 21
et mon mari qui vit avec moi n'a
toujours pas eu d' alerte
ça lui dit toujours pas de contacts à
risque détecté l'appli est bien mes
plantes est donc obligé de désinstaller
réinstaller mais les attestations
dérogatoire ne sont toujours pas à jour
ce n'est pas encore ça mais croisons les
doigts l'application sera peut être
irréprochable lors de la troisième vague